[Música]
y del espacio llegamos a la tierra ya
esta lista en el estudio más romeros
ahora para más romeros salas para hablar
de salud pero antes mar yo le quería
preguntar como a todos les he preguntado
bueno - al bis cuál es su canción
favorita de queens a propósito de los 30
años de la partida de freddie mercury
pues de yo la verdad es que a freddie
mercury tengo que agradecerle por la
canción de bai si queréis que me gusta
mucho ponerme la mientras voy en
bicicleta en bicicleta para mejorar
nuestra salud y estar en forma para
nuestro programa marc pero en redes
sociales nosotros preguntamos las dudas
a nuestros televidentes alrededor de la
vacunación contra el kobe 19 que
descubrimos en esta nueva encuesta de
france 24 pues quisimos hacer este
ejercicio en parte también para saber
por qué hay personas que todavía dudan
si vacunarse o no contra el commit 19
las campañas de vacunación están
avanzando en todo el mundo de hecho la
ema la agencia europea del medicamento
aprobó acaba de recomendar en las
terceras dosis para toda la población
adulta y desde europa hasta américa
latina siguen habiendo personas que
dudan sobre si inocularse o no para
resolver todas estas dudas estamos con
el doctor oscar franco director del
instituto de medicina social y
preventiva de la universidad de berna
como cada miércoles preguntémosle una de
las preguntas una de las dudas que han
aparecido doctor mire una de las
principales cuestiones que tenemos es
sobre la si la vacuna todavía está en
fase experimental o no hemos recibido
varios comentarios al respecto con esta
duda y pues sí podemos saber las
consecuencias a largo plazo de estas
vacunas dado que se han desarrollado en
tan poco tiempo
claro que sí en primer lugar me gustaría
aclarar que es normal tener dudas es
válido hay personas que tienen dudas hay
muchas personas que siguen con dudas es
algo muy normal porque nos estamos
aplicando algo que no lo teníamos antes
y a las personas que tienen dudas les
recomiendo que se informen que no lean
solamente las cadenas de whatsapp o los
posts de facebook sino que lean un poco
más a las personas que no tienen dudas
cuando se enfrenten aquellos que no se
quieren vacunar hay que tener paciencia
y hay que dejarle la libertad de ellos
poder decidir
informándose y dándole buena información
en la medida que sea posible las vacunas
la respuesta es no están en fase
experimental tenemos 8 aprobadas tenemos
15 que están parcialmente autorizadas y
luego hay 150 que están en las últimas
tres fases de aprobación clínica esas sí
están en fase de exploración de esas
tenemos 47 en la fase 3 41 en la fase 2
y 157 en la fase 1 de experimentación
clínica entonces las 8 que les digo que
están aprobadas ya han pasado la fase
experimental y ya están aprobadas por
las diferentes entidades reguladoras
para poderlas aplicar son productos muy
buenos son productos eficaces son
productos seguros y es bueno utilizarlos
porque es peor enfermarse claro informar
raúl como decía el doctor que al final
es lo que tratamos de hacer aquí todos
los días compartir la desinformación
claro por supuesto las noticias falsas y
esas cadenas de whatsapp tan dañinas no
a veces en relación a eso también nos
hacían otra pregunta hemos visto que era
una preocupación que seguía es saliendo
en nuestras redes sociales y es porque
se desarrolló tan rápido la vacuna
contra el joven 19 no eso que parece ser
una buena noticia en algunos casos
también ha generado desconfianza
si no ha sido tan rápido como parece lo
que estamos es vamos en la punta de la
ola por así ponerlo porque llevábamos 30
años por ejemplo con la tecnología de la
rn a mensajeros que lleva
desarrollándose y nos encontramos en una
situación durante la pandemia en la que
tres puntos confluyeron el primero que
toda la investigación todos los
investigadores entonces se enfocaron en
tratar de cuatro a una vacuna segundo
los gobiernos dieron el dinero para
poder desarrollar la vacuna y el tercero
había mucha gente con la enfermedad para
poder experimentar y para poder evaluar
si la vacuna servía por eso ocurrió lo
que ocurrió que hayamos tenido dentro de
un año un año y medio una vacuna que
sirva es casi un milagro pero se debió a
esos factores y se debió a una historia
muy larga de varias décadas de
desarrollo tecnológico que ahora estamos
recogiendo los frutos un doctor también
había muchas personas que dudaban de la
eficacia de la vacuna al no prevenir
contra el contagio o al menos no hacerlo
del todo y de la transmisión no y hemos
visto también en nuestras redes sociales
varias personas que dicen no querer
vacunarse precisamente porque la vacuna
consideran que no es eficaz que les
podemos responder a esas personas
nosotros como científico nos basamos en
la evidencia para poder responder a
estas preguntas la evidencia está muy
clara que la vacuna es eficaz en reducir
mortalidad en prior hospitalización
hasta ahora hemos encontrado que la
vacuna también puede reducir la
capacidad de transmitir pero no evita
del todo que la persona pueda transmitir
que se pueda contagiar y que se pueda
enfermar entonces lo que estamos viendo
hasta ahora es que son muy eficaces son
rangos que estamos hablando de prevenir
la enfermedad severa superior al 85% en
la mayoría de los productos otros del 70
por ciento que son unos niveles
altísimos entonces lo que estamos viendo
son vacunas que basadas en la evidencia
si son capaces de prevenir enfermedad
severa hospitalizaciones y muerte y eso
es lo principal que queremos evitar en
este punto
claro los televidentes también hay
varios que dicen que se han recuperado y
entonces dudan que deban vacunarse se
han recuperado del cob y 19 y pues
cuentan con una cierta inmunidad natural
entonces hay varios que nos dicen que no
hace falta que se vacunen no quede que
debemos decirles al que hemos reiterado
varias veces y ahí yo también marley
entre un productor y meto la cucharada
porque yo también tenía esa duda pero me
vacuné y la verdad que yo ya mentalmente
me siento como más seguro y más confiado
y evidentemente más protegidos y con más
anticuerpos porque tengo el anticuerpos
naturales y kobe 19 mayo de las vacunas
no sé doctor si estoy en lo correcto
estás en lo correcto y los televidentes
están en todo lo correcto porque las
preguntas son muy buenas y muy válidas y
muy importantes de aclarar entonces la
infección puede dar defensas no le da
defensas a todo el mundo y no sabemos
cuánto duran y es la preocupación por
eso se recomienda que la persona que ya
ha pasado el cob y si es posible que se
vacunen con una dosis es de las dos
porque se ha visto que las defensas
continúan y que pueden permanecer
durante un número de meses ahora hemos
visto lo que ocurrió en manaos en
amazonas donde casi el 70% ya había
tenido y unos ocho meses después
volvieron a tener el cob y entonces lo
que vemos es que las defensas duran un
tiempo pero aún no sabemos cuánto tiempo
durante un doctor pues muchas gracias
por resolver todas estas dudas tenemos
una última pregunta para usted también
en conmemoración de estos 30 años de
freddie mercury cuál es su canción
favorita de queens
estaba pensando en el bohemian rhapsody
siempre ha sido la clásica que siempre
me ha gustado mucho pero en estos días
he estado oyendo mucho de los for my
life que es otra vacación muy muy buena
de freddie mercury son las mis artistas
favoritos también una gran balada de
amor así es bueno doctor marc muchísimas
gracias entonces gracias además por
decirnos cuál es su posición favorita de
freddie mercury también hay esta
encuesta en nuestras redes